on april 26 2011 satoshi nakamoto sent
his last known email to gavin anderson
describing that he didn't want to be
seen as some sort of mysterious shadowy
figure satoshi had already stopped
making forum posts a few months before
this unlike youtuber goodbyes though
satoshi was being dead serious as we
haven't heard anything from him in over
a decade
satoshi didn't leave empty-handed though
he took 1 million bitcoins with them
which are currently worth about 60
billion dollars
at this point if bitcoin were to hit
some of the bullish targets in the
hundreds of thousands or millions
satoshi would easily become the world's
richest person and possibly even a
trillionaire but to this day we don't
know the identity of satoshi and
ironically he's become more and more of
the mysterious shadowy figure that he
didn't want to become
so why did satoshi leave and what
happened to him
taking a look back satoshi wasn't always
so quiet when satoshi started coding
bitcoin in 2007 he knew that he would
have to build a strong community around
the project for it to actually build
momentum at first he simply targeted
crypto enthusiasts who could help him
develop bitcoin in october of 2008 he
used a cryptography email list to send
out the first whitepaper of bitcoin this
attracted the attention of some of the
most famous cyberpunks in the world such
as hall finney gavin anderson and nick
sabo while these guys are well respected
as the early visionaries of bitcoin
today back in 2009 these guys were more
or less just weirdos working on some
sort of underground currency satoshi
launched version 0.1 of bitcoin a few
months later in january of 2009 at this
point satoshi was regularly conversing
with early bitcoin developers like hall
finney and gavin anderson but his public
discourse was rather low
however this would quickly change with
the creation of bitcointalk.org
as the name suggests bitcointalk.org was
a community dedicated to discussing the
current state and future of bitcoin
satoshi was actually the one who created
the forum and he made the first post in
november of 2009
so clearly he wasn't trying to avoid the
spotlight at the start in fact he posted
quite heavily between november of 2009
and december of 2010 satoshi made a
total of 575 posts which means that
satoshi was making one to two posts
every single day
through these posts satoshi generally
addressed concerns and criticism
surrounding bitcoin
sometimes he even shared his opinion on
certain aspects of bitcoin or
cryptocurrencies as a whole
for example in one of his last posts
satoshi agreed that miners should get a
fee for all transactions ip changes and
renewals
but just two days after this satoshi
would make his last post and it wasn't
some sort of goodbye post either
his last post was actually about how
bitcoin was extremely vulnerable to a
dos attack and that this along with
several other vulnerabilities needed to
be addressed
maybe this was on purpose it's possible
that satoshi wanted his last post to
draw attention to the shortfalls of
bitcoin or maybe the decision to stop
posting was made after he made a post
we'll probably never know but there are
a few likely reasons as to why he
decided to leave starting with
decentralization
nowadays many crypto investors slash
traders don't really care about the
fundamentals or principles of crypto
they may be a proponent of digitalized
currencies decentralized finance and
blockchain technology but oftentimes
this is not the primary motive behind
their investment the number one reason
they invested into crypto is to make
money now there's nothing wrong with
this but this demographic shift from
cyberpunks to investors has
substantially altered the expectations
of the crypto community many investors
actually like having a ceo type figure
like metallic butyran with ethereum and
charles hoskinson with cardano these
founders are able to directly address
issues with their cryptocurrencies and
provide investors with future outlooks
like ethereum 2.0
but in the early 2010s the crypto
community wasn't a very big fan of such
leaders as it went against the
principles of crypto the entire point of
a decentralized currency is to eliminate
the presence of a central authority the
existence of satoshi himself was a clear
violation of this fundamental principle
so one of the main reasons satoshi left
was likely to embrace the community and
eliminate the central authority i'm
confident that satoshi planned on
leaving the community from the very
beginning but i do think it's possible
that he was forced to leave earlier than
he originally anticipated due to
concerns starting with the risk of
creating an underground currency in
satoshi's last email to gavin he
described that he doesn't like how gavin
as well as the general crypto community
sees satoshi as a dark mysterious figure
he goes on to emphasize that this simply
made it easier for the media to paint
bitcoin as a pirate currency
given the decentralized nature of
bitcoin it's already super prone to
illicit activities
i mean if you just scroll down to the
comments section of this video i'm sure
there's an abundance of crypto experts
named mary jane that can double your
money in two hours and though mary jane
is a terrible person for scamming
desperate individuals out of a few
hundred or a few thousand dollars the
crimes associated with bitcoin are
oftentimes much larger like tax evasion
money laundering drug dealing ransoms
and who knows what else
now these crimes are going to take place
with or without satoshi but it's only a
matter of time until the media paints
satoshi as a nefarious person himself
you might be saying that the media
doesn't cast negative light on vitalik
buterin or charles hoskinson but there
are two key differences between satoshi
and these two first of all this was 10
years ago when the general consensus was
that bitcoin was either a scam a pirate
currency or both and second of all the
identities of vitalik and charles are
public so there's no speculation as to
who might have created it with satoshi
though it wouldn't take long for the
media to make connections between him
and some international fugitive it was
just a matter of time until we saw
articles suggesting that satoshi created
bitcoin in order to fund and operate his
underground arms network wait never mind
that's already a thing can you imagine
how rampant such speculation would be if
satoshi was still posting but remained
anonymous at that rate it would
basically be impossible for satoshi to
remain anonymous and that brings us to
the final reason that satoshi left which
was a threat to his anonymity now we're
not sure about how satoshi personally
feels about publicity and being a
figurehead but it's pretty clear that he
had objective reservations to being a
figurehead even if satoshi left the
development scene and gave up his role
as the leader of bitcoin if his identity
was known he could never truly eliminate
his day-to-day influence on bitcoin for
example if you sold some bitcoins to
just buy a house you'd see a plethora of
articles questioning if satoshi is
dumping at the top
similarly if you were to support a new
crypto project that crypto would likely
go to the moon in 20 minutes the best
modern day example of what satoshi's
influence may look like is elon musk
when elon announced that tesla bought
bitcoin bitcoin was actually
experiencing a pretty serious correction
bitcoin had corrected from 40k down to
27k and looked like it was about to test
a breakout at 20k but elon's
announcement skyrocketed bitcoin to 60k
instead similarly elon announcing that
tesla will stop accepting bitcoin was
the start of the summer bear market now
honestly i don't think elon was actually
the key reason for the pump in february
or the dump in may
bitcoin whale simply used elon as an
excuse to pump crypto in february and
take profits in may but as far as the
media and the general public are
concerned elon pumped and dumped bitcoin
and i don't think i need to even mention
elon's influence on doge the truth is
even if satoshi gave up his central
authority he could never avoid
influencing the markets if his identity
was public and in 2010 his anonymity was
in jeopardy as we previously discussed
the media was likely to pump out
increasingly negative articles on him
the longer he was anonymous this would
eventually lead to a tipping point at
which satoshi would either have to live
with bitcoin being branded as a pirate
currency or he would have to reveal his
identity to prove his good intentions
satoshi didn't want to go down either of
these paths so he left the road before
the situation got this bad even if the
media didn't get him though the crypto
community was out to get him not in a
nefarious way but out of curiosity a
large portion of the bitcoin community
was curious as to who created bitcoin
they were collecting the crumbs that
satoshi accidentally left behind and
starting to piece together his identity
also let's keep in mind that we're
dealing with a group of super nerds who
like to code bitcoin during their free
time if satoshi kept posting it it was
just a matter of time until someone
found his address or his facebook page
so at the end of the day satoshi left to
protect the decentralized nature of
bitcoin shift the focus to the community
avoid becoming a figurehead and protect
his anonymity ironically i actually have
a full video on the top contenders for
satoshi but anyway now that we answered
why satoshi left bitcoin we only have
one question left where is he today well
the general consensus is that there are
really only two possibilities the first
option is that he's dead maybe satoshi
didn't stop posting because he was
trying to protect his anonymity it's
possible that satoshi left because he
was ill and eventually died the top
contender supporting this theory is a
man named hall finney hall finney is a
cyberpunk who was involved with the
bitcoin basically from day one in fact
he was the recipient of the first
bitcoin transaction
but unfortunately he was diagnosed with
als and became increasingly immobilized
before he died in august of 2014. the
other leading theory is that satoshi
never actually left bitcoin he gave up
the elias satoshi but he continued to be
part of the community using his real
identity this way he could still work on
bitcoin but avoid all the pressures of
being satoshi the top contenders for
this theory include gavin anderson and
nick sabo gavin anderson was the one
that led bitcoin development after
satoshi left so maybe satoshi just
handed the reigns to himself on the
other hand nick skapel developed
something called big gold which was
yearly similar to bitcoin way back in
1998. maybe he decided to launch a
refined version of bitgold called
bitcoin there is also the possibility
that satoshi is just some random
programmer that we've never heard of but
this is the least likely option in all
likelihood satoshi was probably a
well-respected figure within the crypto
and cyberpunk community well before
bitcoin was a thing but that's just what
i think what do you guys think happened
to bitcoin's founder comment that down
below also drop a like if you respect
satoshi's choice to stay anonymous and
of course consider joining our discord
community to suggest future video ideas
and consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered but until
then i'm hari and i'll see you guys on
the next one